Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
I'm Farron cousins from wearing a fire sitting
in to David Pakman today.
Follow me on Twitter at fair and balanced.
You also find me on Instagram and Facebook
at that same handle at fair and balanced.
Uh, we've got a little bit more Trump news
to talk about today because the man got a
little bit more bad news yesterday.
And that bad news came in the form of a court
ruling by Judge Ahmet Mehta, who said that,
I'm sorry Donald Trump administration, but
I'm not going to block the Democrats request
to get your financial documents.
Now, if you rewind the clock about a week
ago when the Trump administration made these
arguments in court in front of Judge Metta,
Judge Mehta at the time basically told Trump's
lawyers, that's your arguments, don't hold
any water.
Because the Trump lawyers were trying to say,
Democrats can't request Donald Trump's financial
documents because it's not related to any
legislation that they're trying to pass in.
Congress's job, as we all know, is only to
pass legislation.
And the judge said, no, no, really it's not.
That's not how the separation of powers work.
They actually also have oversight authority
of the executive branch.
And so this would fall within the things they
are legally allowed to do, even if it's not
related to legislation.
But then the judge said, but listen, I understand
the importance of this and I'm in a way, both
sides of the arguments.
I'm going to look at all the evidence and
I'm going to take some time before a hand
down this ruling because I don't want to rush
it.
That was the mature, responsible, professional
and legally correct thing for this judge to
do.
And then Monday hands down the ruling and
he says, yeah, Republicans.
I thought about it and listen, your arguments,
they were garbage.
They don't work.
They don't hold up.
It flies in the face of the separation of
powers.
And so yes, therefore the Democrats 100% can
get their hands on Donald Trump's financial
records.
Now, Trump immediately got angry and he told
reporters he's going to appeal it and he's
furious that this Obama appointed judge, he
kept calling him and Obama appointed judge.
In fact, at one point he said it was a recently
appointed a bomb Obama judge recently.
So yes, Obama came out of retirement while
Trump was president to go ahead and just to
point this judge, the guy has been out of
office for two and a half years.
It's not exactly recent Trump, but nonetheless,
yeah, Obama did appoint this judge and this
judge 100% did what any normal, well respected
person who understands the law would do and
they smacked down your lawyers because their
argument was absolute garbage.
You know, there is one theme that's developing
throughout the Trump administration and we've
seen it on unfold very publicly and that is
the fact that this man has some of the worst
lawyers imaginable.
I mean, think about it, Michael Cohen, he's
in jail now.
He will be for the next three years.
Rudy Giuliani, that man actually went on TV
multiple different times and implicated Donald
Trump in crimes and that was supposed to be
as client j secular.
Well, we all know the story that emerged yesterday.
We're going to talk about that a little bit
later in the bonus show, but Jay Sekulow apparently
ordered Michael Cohen to lie to Congress and
then you have these bone.
Had lawyers who go into court acting like
they don't understand the roles that Congress
constitutionally has.
And the judge has to say, listen, you don't
seem to understand how congress works, but
they're allowed to do this.
So yeah, Trump clearly has a history of hiring
horrible people to be his lawyers.
Um, and to that I say, please continue this.
Uh, it's a lot of fun watching your lawyers
go into court and reading these filings and
seeing how clueless they are and how desperate
they are to protect whatever it is you're
hiding.
So please continue to hire from the bottom
of the barrel because it's making life for
the rest of us.
So much more entertaining, but to the actual
ruling, right?
I mean, not just the ruling from the judge,
but what it means.
It means, as of right now, but of course Trump's
gonna appeal it Democrats could get their
hands on the financial records.
And the big question is obviously, what the
heck is Donald Trump hiding?
You know, he also claimed after going after
this quote, Obama appointed judge that he
has had the most transparent administration
in history.
He's either completely delusional or he thinks
everybody in this country is an absolute idiot.
If he thinks he can get away with saying that
we can't see his grades from college or high
school, we can't see his medical records,
we can't see his tax returns.
We can't see his financial records, we can't
see his business holdings.
There is nothing transparent about Donald
Trump except his hair, but nonetheless, he
is hiding something that much has pretty obvious.
Right folks.
You don't go through all of this wreck a effort.
You don't threaten to sue schools if they
release your grades.
If you're not trying to hide something, you
don't fight congressional subpoenas in court
and less you're trying to prevent congress
from seeing something you don't want them
to see.
The big question is what is he hiding?
Is He hiding bank fraud?
Well, representative Ted lieu made a pretty
strong case during Michael Cohen's testimony
to Congress that Donald Trump committed bank
fraud and based on the cooperation that Deutsche
Bank has had so far with congressional Democrats,
it seems pretty obvious that he inflated his
net worth in order to secure a loan.
That's fraud.
You can't do that.
Is there potential money laundering?
Oh, again, the folks at Deutsche Bank really
seem to think that there was, not just with
Trump, but with Jared Kushner.
So there's that.
But I think the biggest thing this man wants
to hide, because I think he thinks he can
get away with any criminal activity that doesn't
bother him, never has never will, is a man
who's gotten away with quite literally everything
for his entire life.
But what he can't get away with is destroying
his reputation.
I think these financial documents would tell
us that Donald Trump does not have as much
money as he says he has.
And if that were to be the case, that would
absolutely destroy the image that he has spent
his entire life crafting.
And there is no common back from that.
You know, he could do his best to lie his
way out of criminal activity.
He's already lied his way about the out of
the fact that he lost all that money.
You know, trying to say that, oh no, it was
just, you kind of write these numbers and
it's almost fraud, but it's totally not fraud.
And everybody did it except I didn't actually
do that.
So you did lose the money.
All he did was just spew out a bunch of words,
further confusing the public, and suddenly
everybody split on whether or not the man
did lose the money or if he committed fraud
or if he did pay taxes or what the hell is
going on.
Nobody knows.
So he thinks he can lie his way out of criminal
activity is all I'm trying to say.
But he can't lie his way out of the fact that
he may not have as much money as he wants
us to think he does.
And that would destroy him.
It wouldn't end his presidency, but he would
absolutely deliver a blow to his ego that
I do not know this man would ever be able
to physically and emotionally overcome because
that is the thing that matters the most to
him.
Yes, this man loves money more than I have
ever seen a human being love money.
Yeah.
But that money is what made that ego, and
if we find out that the money's not there,
then suddenly his lifetime of lies creating
this facade comes crumbling to the ground
and this man would never be able to recover
from that.